sadiq
khan is the current mayor of london he
has a lot of control
and he is saying that he plans to bring
in rent control
throughout london this is an abysmal
idea so i had to shoot a video to talk
about
what rent control is and plead with the
mayor of london
to change his mind and to stop deceiving
people because i think that he knows
it's a terrible idea
and i think that he's just saying that
to try and get votes for the new
election
that's happening in may so let me inform
you and educate you what rent control
is and i would highly suggest that we
make a stand against
stupid ideas like rent control
rent control for anyone that doesn't
know is basically when you cap
rents now it sounds wonderful it sounds
great
it sounds with the way the media talk
about it it sounds like oh that's a good
idea because what they say is
the whole media our anti-landlord
their anti-landlord they're anti-rich
people okay no problem
but what they say is they say that rent
control means that landlords
can't put their rent too high and take
advantage of tenants
now as a tenant myself okay i'm a tenant
i'm also a landlord i'm also
a as someone that's well researched and
understands a little bit about history
and economics
from every which angle no matter which
way i look at this i say it's an
absolutely
crazy ludicrous [ __ ]
thing to do and pretty much every
economist
would agree with me on this whether
they're left whether they're right they
would agree
that rent control is a bad idea for
everybody and it will devastate london
if it happens
like it in new york i mean
why why don't we just look at history
i'm pretty sure sadiq knows this
now this is what sadiq said he said that
the arguments
for rent control are overwhelming
what are they what are the arguments
name them to me how are they
overwhelming
what's the argument for rent control
besides playing on
emotions and sensational stories about
poor people that couldn't quite afford
their rent
and choosing one cat but what are the
arguments help me out sadiq
and then he says and
londoners overwhelmingly want it to
happen
the reason londoners overwhelmingly want
it to happen is because they don't
understand the effects
let me let me explain okay rent control
let's say that they cap rents at a
certain amount
and they say you can't you can't rent
somewhere for more than five grand
all right and you can what's gonna
happen well
all the people that want to pay more
than five grand like me
i rent my house i pay seven and a half
thousand pounds a month if if they said
you can't pay more than seven and a half
thousand pounds a month
then i would then be forced as a tenant
to be like oh well i have to find
somewhere cheaper then
i'm just gonna get my house cheaper it's
gonna be pulled from the market
so me is a tenant that wants to pay a
really high rent because i want a nice
place
it's gonna it's gonna take very
expensive
tenants that want very expensive rents
and it's gonna force them
to have to rent somewhere more
affordable more cheaper which is gonna
do what which is gonna mean
more competition with the tenants that
can only afford it so people like me
who i'm pretty rich i'm going to be now
taking houses
because i'm queuing up to rent houses
that are more affordable taking
affordable houses
it's going to it's going to reduce the
amount of properties on the market
and there'll be less affordable
accommodation i mean that's the first
reason straight away it doesn't make any
sense
i mean this whole idea of greedy
landlords is not true anyway
i would argue that a greedy landlord
doesn't really exist because if you're a
greedy landlord and you go i'm gonna
hike my rents up what's gonna happen is
you're gonna push your rents up and
you're gonna have an empty property
no one's gonna pay it if it's if you're
trying to if you're trying to charge
too much people just go i'm not gonna
pay right
it's a free market so if you put your
rents really high and the house isn't
worth it
people are just going to not rent it the
only way people are going to rent it
when you put the rent high is if it's
worth it
so the idea of rent control is anti
a free market it's terrible number two
second reason and there's a whole bunch
of reasons second reason why
rent control is a terrible idea is
because
investors at the moment there's a lot of
investors that are investing into london
they're buying apartments they're buying
affordable property
and they're buying luxury property and
everything in between and they're
renting those properties out they're
buying it as an investment
if rent control is a thing in london
it's going to mean that all investors
will not want to buy in london anymore
and investors
like me are going to start buying in
other areas
investors from hong kong and china and
london
aren't going to want to buy properties
to rent them out anymore in london so
they're going to go to other areas
so what's that going to mean for london
it's going to mean that there's less
supply there's not as much supply
anymore and when there's not as much
supply anymore what does that mean it
means it's going to push the prices up
but then there's rent control so
it's just it's just ludicrous it's going
to mean that there's queues and queues
like in new york like in los angeles
there's going to be cues and queues of
people
wanting to rent but there won't be any
accommodation
there won't be any accommodation anymore
there won't be anywhere to run because
the government have stepped in with some
stupid rule and tried to cap rents
unnecessarily houses cannot become more
affordable
unless they become more available and
the whole concept
of rent control trying to cap the rent
is trying to
provide more affordable accommodation
but it actually has the opposite effect
thirdly developers do you think that
developers are going to want to build
come and build accommodation apartments
houses in an area
whereby they know once they've built
them the rent is capped and the answer
is
no and we've got a massive
shortage sadiq you're behind massively
behind
on the on houses that need to be built
in london so why are you trying to bring
in rent control which is they're going
to
put off potential developers coming into
the area
because that if a developer and if a
developer does come into the area which
they probably wouldn't
they're going to either be building
because they know the rent control
they're going to be building
really crappy little apartments because
i think oh well the rent's going to be
capped anyway
so it's just going to bring a a whole
bunch of nasty
crummy apartments into london which is
going to which is going to not help with
lots of things like the crimes
and all sorts or they're going to build
really high-end luxury
apartments to sell to rich people it's
rent control will make the rich richer
poorer bigger divide opposite of what
you say you're trying to do and i think
you know this sadiq i think you're doing
it just for votes
surely before you announce that there's
so many arguments for rent control
surely before you pledged if you're
re-elected as mayor you're gonna bring
in rent control surely you should have
looked at
what happened in new york and what
happened in los angeles
when it happened i mean in new york
there was instances where when rent
control came in
tenants were paying a third of what they
should have been paying and they just
said oh well
i'm playing a third of what she was
playing and and they refused to leave
just stayed there for 25 years
and then the landlords get upset so the
landlords say well i want to make i need
to make a profit so what do they do
well the landlords just say well i'm not
fixing anything in the property then
i'm not going to maintain it forget it
you're paying such a cheap rent
if i'm being forced to not be able to
charge more you're taking an advantage
and it just creates this nasty friction
where you end up with houses
the tenants can't afford to fix the
houses and the landlords refuse
and in new york you've got all these
awful situations with
properties getting run down
it distorts the market we need a free
market
a free market will always lead to a
win-win in business
because business is when you have a
willing buyer and a willing seller
a willing tenant that wants to pay the
rent and the willing landlord that
charges the rent that he thinks is worth
supplying demand it's fair it's nice
when the government try and step in
and and enforce um
capped rents and things like that it
always brings devastation
always i went to new york i went to new
york to do a financial freedom challenge
and guess what within about two days i
realized this isn't gonna happen
the whole housing economy in new york is
so distorted and strange and there's
loads of people on the streets why is
there such a massive um
homeless problem in new york maybe it's
because there's no properties to rent
affordable properties because they
brought in rent caps which actually
means that there's no properties to rent
at all because it completely ruins the
whole market
we need a free market so listen don't
just take my word for it
go and do your research on rent control
and then ask sadiq
khan what are all these overwhelming
arguments for rent control because i
can't find any
ask him the question and i would say
please don't vote for
sadiq if you live in london i like brian
rose
i like his policies i like brian rose or
or sean bailey anyone but siddique
hashtag gets the deke out
study rank control i'll be doing more
videos
i'll be keeping i'll be keeping you
posted on exactly what's happening in
london on exactly what's happening with
the housing market so subscribe to my
channel for more updates
if you like my videos smash the like
button but please don't vote for the dig